[Applaudissements]
jean miche ans franchement ça s'arrêtera
programme très familial il n'y a pas
beaucoup la télévision lie les
programmes contre les épreuves contre m
en excuse dit mathieu en a toujours des
nouvelles c'est bien la première fois
qu'il la faisait celles qui restent
parce que c'est des grands classiques on
a envie de revoir comme le poteau et
cetera au parcours du combattant
on a envie de les voir et les cadres et
des candidats qui auparavant sur le
récit on s'attache malaria il ya tout il
ya la stratégie et d'émotion galerie
photos
alors c'est une super épreuve mais ça
n'a aucun intérêt ça vous dit de rester
32 35 minutes devant devant de personnes
debout sur un poteau à tout tu as bien
deux heures sur une top 3
ah bon
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça paraît
vous saurez de m
[Applaudissements]
la malibu dangereux d'ailleurs mal je te
jure en poussette quant à 10 les coûts
d'hôtes à dire ouais je me suis dit bon
ivanova mail
[Rires]
je savais pas pourquoi c'est le guerrier
je jamais fait deux heures cela je
pleure mais je me plante de régler le
plus fou
ce mec est fou sur décoller avec
jean-luc se bat mais on atteint vraiment
d'atteindre une île fous rires oui il a
préféré jouer ou presque pour rien ouais
on a un truc qu'il fallait pas louper
aussi